Googlers. Please welcome to the
stage Tyler Perry, Taraji p Henson.
[inaudible]
you are welcome.
Where,
how do we do cinema? You sit in the
middle. Okay. Lyrics at the end.
Is everybody doing?
You look good.
You look great. Yeah. You
look real everyday but you
look really good for that.
I how quickly I'll fix that. You're
going to fix that real quick. Thank you.
Awesome guys.
Thank you for coming to Google.
I think this is your first time here
for trade. It is. Yes. Yes. First Time,
I know you've done a
Google plus hangout if,
I don't know if you've actually
done it on our campus. So welcome.
I have not and I'm very excited to be
here and uh, we're excited to have you.
And for those Googlers who didn't
know right before we came in,
Tyler Teraji and lyric actually popped
into a coding class that was happening
right over here with young
women's leadership academy.
So we had about a dozen young
ladies from Queens who, uh,
I think they were doing some,
uh,
VR coding and they just popped
in. So all that screaming, yes,
I heard it wasn't me. It was,
no, it was where you William?
Yes. I wish. Anyway, thank
you guys. So I'm sorry. I,
let me just give me right now guys.
I'm tired and I'm stupid when I'm tired.
So this and this may go straight silly.
Just, just no, I'm just be prepared.
I read the disclaimer, the disclaimer.
Okay. All right. All right. I'm ready.
And this is not being filmed at all,
so, okay, good. Good, good. All right.
You won't take those off now.
So acrimony,
uh,
the name kind of says it all if
you know what the definition is.
And I was about to say,
so, uh, bitterness, ranker,
anger, anger, rage, Alice. I didn't
know what the definition was. Oh,
I'd literally,
I'd written this script and I was like,
I got to find a title for it.
And I was watching,
he was watching CNN and somebody
was describing our president
and you were like, and they
said, it's acrimonious. I said,
what is that word into this angle?
That's the title of the movie
theaters March 30. Well, you
answered my first question.
How did you edited you come up with the,
I already knew you were going there.
There you go.
Okay.
Um,
but this movie is,
is a little bit of a departure
from what you're known for your,
you're a worldwide brand
known for making movies, um,
that are humorous
and dramatic and watch
it be careful. Yeah. But,
but this is a thriller. Yeah, no,
it's, it's a big departure for me.
After doing gone girl and working with
David Fincher and seeing his brilliance
and,
and he would watch he and Ben Affleck
and on the brakes talk about cameras and
lighting and shots and this Hitchcock
kind of filled that they wanted and they
want to make sure that the, the
way the light falls, I'm like,
what the hell are they talking about? So
I really started paying attention to it.
And then when I saw gone
girl come together, I said,
I want to do something like
this. So I started, I had
this idea for a while and I,
and I started riding again.
And of course there was only one
person who could play Melinda.
And that's to Razi p.
So did you, did you write the role of
Belinda with Taraji and mine? Merlin,
Linda, Linda, sorry. Yeah,
that Belinda's for someone
else that's called by. Oh
my God,
yes. But no, totally wrote it
with her in mind because you know,
when I start writing a few of the scenes,
what happens is the characters start,
they speak to me that I could, I
could hear them as I'm, as I'm typing.
And then pretty soon I
started to see a face and I,
the first face I saw was hers.
And then he calls me and I'm like in
the middle of filming and by, Yep.
I'm not done until months later.
So I'm like, sure, I'll do it.
My high eight it says, he said, no, no.
Yeah cause nobody,
let me tell you something.
Nobody does a film while they're shooting
their television shows because you
don't have the time. It's, it's 1618 hours
a day, six, seven days a week sometimes.
So He'd some crazy schedule. But
uh, for some reason she said yes.
Well cause you wouldn't go away.
You wouldn't take no for
an answer because I was,
I tried to give him every excuse.
I was like, Tyler, I am cookie.
I was like,
how do I di program my
instrument being cookie?
He was like, he let me
finish. He was like, okay,
you've been living with cookie for
three years now and you got that.
You can come and do this,
and I was like, okay.
I was so nervous and scared and that's
why I did it because if it doesn't scare
me then I'm not going to change.
I'm not going to transform it anyway,
so I don't do roles that don't really
scare me. Not unless the check is good.
First scene that we shot, it
was cookie, the first thing,
the very first and I pulled you
aside and said, nope, that's cocky.
What was the first scene?
It didn't make it in the movie.
It's the trashcan where you come out
and you went to the trashcan and the and
the his, his, his, his ideas
in the trashcan. He dropped
a cigarette ash on it.
He's like, thank you lord that she
is open. Then you get in the car here
dry. Oh, how you cut that? Cause
that was because that was cooking.
Well you call me in the middle
of the vehicle, you said
no, no, no, but no, no, no.
I say that to say that. So I
say that to say this. She's
like, you know what, you right.
You right now watch this. She comes
back and she's this, she's Melinda.
Everything, the boys, the boys,
the eyes that this the, the way this
woman looks up at, at it, at him,
it's chilling. Man. It was crazy though.
It's true. And I was looking at that,
that character, while I have
been broken bleeding and I was,
I was kind of shocked. I, I mean you,
you played strong characters,
tough characters. Um,
I have get to see you play a character
like this and it seemed like it was,
it was kind of scary.
I mean it was definitely scary.
I've been waiting for this APP
ever since I seen fatal attraction.
I been gunning for a character like
this and it was great because I'm always
playing the righteous female, you know,
she's really always the moral compass,
you know, to stand up kind
of woman's strong and pow,
I wanted to do this because she's
that. But in another light, right?
He's made up this story and um, I
mean, we've all been there. You know,
you man get a tax. It's a simple tax.
It could be from a cousin, you know,
maybe he didn't see the cousin
and 10 years, I don't know.
But we will take that and
run with a child. It says
his woman, he's been dating,
but he has a whole nother family out.
I don't know about,
every woman in here is
not agreeing with you
talked about,
I will take something and we're all
capable of it, but then there's that one.
We're capable because then there's that
one part of you that's the rational
where you got to go, okay, this is
stupid. Like I can't, this didn't,
this is not happening. Well, Melinda
didn't listen to that voice. Right.
She just took her story and ran with it.
Well. Right. I mean, she, she's pure rage.
And as I remember,
if I remember correctly,
very early on in the movie as Melinda's
talking about herself, she says,
my rage is like this discreet thing.
It's like something that's
separate and apart from, yeah. Um,
which is kind of amazing and I want to
come to come back to that because you
touch upon mental health just
a little bit in the movie.
And I wanted to explore
that more, but, uh,
I wanted to get more into the character
of Melinda and then go to go to lyric
because, um, the, the,
the character seems to be off to save,
to save the, to say the least. Did you,
and you talked about your, you know,
what you did to build out that character,
basically. Fan, you're off.
It was Tyler.
That's what you think about it.
But she's also, she, she's broke and
she's, and she's hurting. So his,
through his lyrics are, so
there's, there's a lot there,
but I wanted to know how you,
how you gotten into that camera.
Well, I mean, we've all had a broken
heart. If you haven't, you haven't loved.
But you know,
I've had those moments where I had to
talk myself out of scratching up a car or
throwing a brick through. Come on.
You know when your heart is hurting,
you want that person hurt.
People hurt people. Right?
So if you hurt me,
my natural reaction is to get you back.
Right?
So,
but then you have to grow up and you
have to realize that jail is not for me.
So I'm gonna keep driving and pretend like
I don't see the car. You know, I'm not.
So this was a role for me to act out
all of those things I thought about and
wanted to do
and not go to jail,
including show up with an ax. But yeah.
Good. Yeah. Right. Yeah, exactly. Yeah,
exactly. So, so
I had, this hair is driving
me crazy. I'm so sorry. Okay.
This is what I did with on set. We'll
be in a serious thing. She'll be like,
and if you do that again,
what the hell is going on with his hair?
Right here is what we dealt
with all the time. All the time.
Be looking at me like sweet.
Why? Because the people,
I have a weird way of
operating like working,
you know you have act is
where you have to be quiet.
You can't move you right
there. Sorry. She on her phone.
I don't really like that and I could
add in the middle of a damn circus.
I mean literally and I'll do
these scenes where I'm just like,
and everybody's like tip toeing
around me and then they'll,
they'll cut and I'm like, yeah.
So anyway, tower last night,
various stuff.
Was that off putting lyric,
we're working working that way or
you do you work a different way?
It's very calm. Just no,
this is all going to be proud to change.
It's about to get real calm.
Real leading man. Real sexy. Right.
Where the peanut gallery also
asking me a question. Go ahead.
I forgot the question.
Was this your first time acting
with Teraji? It was. And then
how was that?
It was a great experience.
Um,
I never thought that this moment and
this opportunity would be in my career.
So it was something that was a surreal,
still beside myself a year later.
So I'm working with,
with Toronto was great because I know
from seeing her own empire I've seen on
our work before. Yeah.
I was just like, okay,
I got to come prepared. I gotta
make sure that, um, didn't,
I didn't know she was that intense.
I had no idea. She was intense. I,
I like to believe that her characters
are different than the person,
so I didn't think of
her as cookie. But, um,
the professionalism that, uh, that she
brought to the set was second to none.
And um, I came prepared. I'm always
prepared. I like to believe that.
But then when I saw the level of
professionalism after one could think,
you know,
you could just relax
because I've made it, you
know, got a big show, you know,
you could come on and just like stop a
set because you know that one hair is out
of place, not the thing, but
it was never that. It was like,
like what you see is what it
is. Yeah. I was very thankful,
but I know really I your check?
No,
no,
we didn't really get a lot of time
together because it was so fast.
She didn't want to spend time.
She um,
there was a disclaimer to
not spend any time. Well no,
that's kind of remarkable
though because while the, the,
the movie sidle characters you really,
that's about the relationship
between your character. Robert,
fix this cause this is called Virgo
for you. I also know you're a,
you're a stickler for details.
Yeah.
Yeah. He, I'm going to say this. I don't
know where you were in the question,
but I just have to begin my presentation.
I never, I had never met lyric before.
I didn't know. And I trust Tyler.
So he says this guy's great.
So of course I Google and I can
call my guy from finance them. Okay.
But they know, you know, cause
it's all about a chemistry.
You know the great thing
about this is that you know,
whether the chemistry was there or not,
it was okay because we really didn't
like each other for the part of the film
that we started.
You know,
cause they start with the kids
first plank us and then we grow up.
So by the time we're,
we come in as ourselves and the character
in a movie, we don't like each other.
Like the, the relationship has fallen
apart. So I wasn't like, I, you know,
the chemistry didn't really have to
be there as if we were madly in love,
but it still helps to show
a pass that there was,
you can see the chemistry used
to be there something. Right.
And so when I met him,
I remember the first thing we did for me
is the eyes and his eyes are so like he
was so vulnerable. Yeah.
Something in his eyes so strong,
but yet he could break in any moment
and that's where that character was.
And not just as like Tyler where to
find him a year later I look up and he
everywhere.
Yeah.
Fortunate to lay eyes on some amazing
talent before they, before they hit.
And he's definitely one of those things.
And I think that its features
going to be so amazing because,
because he is an incredible actor.
He is.
Just what he brings in the vulnerability
and I mean he's leading man material.
Yeah, absolutely. And unfortunately
I don't see a lot of bad anymore,
especially in men of color, so,
but he is definitely that. And if,
and I can tell you when you're,
when we're going down casting,
trying to cast a movie and you start
looking for the leading man that lit up,
I lead a man of color. That list
is really short, really short.
So he definitely should be on that list.
My checks don't have them
while I can I,
can I tell you my favorite part?
Sure. [inaudible] is the, for the,
the second I think is a second scene or
something when she's in with a therapist,
there's a camera move that I did that,
that it's just nothing special.
It's just on low on a track
and it just pushes in on her.
And it's about a four minute
scene that I didn't want to cut.
I didn't want to edit it at all.
I want it to be raw so people can see
the brilliance in this woman. I mean, I,
so that scene is uncut.
She's sitting,
she's sitting there on the sofa doing
this long monologue and she sets up the
whole movie. But it shows you
how brilliant, what, what,
how broken she has is as an actor.
It's incredible. It's incredible.
And I love it that way on purpose.
So be nerve wracking, hopefully that,
that scene,
it's so sad.
Why you scared the hell out of nights.
It scared me when she saw it back to
your site because it's like, who is that?
I'm like,
well,
I'm gonna tell you why as an actress
doing television is scared me because we
didn't cut. Right. He was like,
no, I need this all in one take.
And we only had for three days to do it.
It doesn't hold my whole part of the film.
We shot in four days.
The whole movie was done in eight days.
We have to protect this man because no,
seriously, because he can, he
can read a lot of jobs. Yes.
He's a lot of people don't, well,
you know, let's just set up,
we don't want miss the ferry to come.
I'm missing,
but I do do.
I'll go out
there. There will be a lot of haters.
No, I won't because he's getting, I mean,
you know, so many people think their
jobs are important, but you know,
we won't go there. Let's keep
talking about the movie. But um,
so I was so nervous because I had so much
dialogue to say and I didn't have the
luxury of cut. Oh, can I do, can
we just pick it up from here?
And it was like he needed all
of that dialogue in one take,
but that's when that theater
training came in. Yeah.
Because I wanted the
audience to see when you
throw an accurate or
role and you don't cut,
you don't cut like work for
those of you on our cutters,
you jump to a close up or you jumped to
a side shot. He jumped into the chat.
It's one shot pushing in on her as
she delivers. Like it's chilling.
And if you don't know who Melinda is
in that moment at the beginning of the
movie, you won't. Yeah. The,
the other character though,
Robert,
I said to till lyric as we
were coming in and I said,
I actually thought that character that
you wrote was the most complicated one
because it's, it's through his
character that you shift perspective.
And that's the really,
one of the great things about the movie
is because you think it's this movie
about, you know, trust and betrayal
and you know, there's this, you know,
steadfast woman who is yet this
unfaithful man and this is revenge.
And actually it's a different story.
It's a different,
because if you notice in the
beginning of the movie, it's told,
we can't tell them the room has this
room scene. I don't think that they have.
So you're trying not to no, no, no.
I just started to set it up though
in the beginning of the movie, she,
she is telling the story from
our point of view, right?
So you're in it from her point of view
and then there's a shift where you go,
wait a minute, wait, there's
this. Right? What is she saying?
Did that really happen?
And was that true?
And you realize that as
you're watching the film,
that there are two perspectives to this
is like in every relationship that goes
bad, there's her side and there's his side
or there's his side, his side, her side,
her side.
Yeah.
And then the, and then there's the truth.
And I, and this was born out of it,
out of me counseling a lot of friends
who have gone through things and I would
sit down with them and that I would be
friends with him or friends with her.
And then we'd sit down and have
a conversation, uh, separately.
And they saw two different moments that
both the tore them apart. And I was like,
how could this be that?
And I would drive,
I remember really trying to get this
one person to see this other side of it.
And she couldn't,
she would not allow it because what it
would mean is that she would have to take
responsibility in her own and what
she did wrong. So yeah. Yeah. Right.
That was my,
there were a few Aha moments
and that was definitely an Aha,
Aha moment when it switched perspectives.
And it's so easy how we're so quick to
jump on the girl's side because y'all do
that though. Do that. You'll get all
your girlfriends and you get your,
you get your girl nation
to come up against.
He did it because he
wrote a movie like that.
There's always another
side. Just just I, I,
I'm pretty good about taking a moment and
stepping back and like even when I can
remove the emotion within
myself, I'm be like, okay,
let me just look at this from both sides
because a lot of times people run out
on relationships that could have,
could have been really, really good,
but they couldn't remove themselves
from the middle of the emotion.
If you can take yourself out of it and
step back for a minute and go, okay,
maybe I could have handled this
better or maybe I could have did this,
but first thing you ask yourself is,
what did I do wrong?
Own your own stuff first and
then you can work on fixing it.
Hey, hey, hey, hey,
hey, hey, come, come back.
I have never heard anybody say they were
going along to best. Fascinating goal.
That's the new movement. Be a synagogue,
Girls Bill Gurley.
Agrimonia
know how to spell that.
You don't understand lyric
lyric looking just like
I said. Okay. Cause I moved really fast
but he came here but the camera Andy does.
Okay. And everybody get ob. It makes
her gut is right brain Raylynn's okay,
let's go
lyrical code when you go.
I'm sorry.
Maybe I'm sorry,
I need to explain cause I'm the director.
Let me explain to you what, I'm sorry. I
just thought you got it. But yeah, yeah,
I you do them out of sequence also. Right?
So yeah, this was, this was the, I'm sorry
I have to say this,
we have totally taken over your,
I know
I did my homework. I was watching like
youtube clips in like all sorts of things.
Anyway. It's all right. Wait,
Fillmore is, despite saying he
shows up and all hell breaks loose.
Me and my sisters jump is a yes.
But it was
crazy because he had Tyler again,
his brilliance,
he had all of these cameras set up to get
all of the angles. So this cut out six,
six cameras.
So we had the crane shoddy out of
somebody with a steady cam on the track.
There were cameras everywhere.
This is unheard of and a feature.
You do it for five, 10 times to get all of
those angles. We did it. What two, three,
two takes at the most. Um, and what
he would do, we would start the fight.
So if I got body hair
wasn't, it wasn't supposed to be
a fight. Yeah, it wasn't enough.
It ended up [inaudible] high was because
he never read that in the script.
I don't know.
It wasn't, it wasn't a fight.
It was, it was a disagreement.
And then
after,
after I tell her what's happening,
I leave to go about my business and she
decided that it's not going to go like
that. It's going to be a fight. And it
ended up on the front lawn of the house.
The scene is supposed to be in the house.
Well, that scene and I thought like,
I'm like, wow, that's real. That's,
but this is no, this,
this is one of those moments where I
didn't fill him in. It was not filled in.
We talked about it, but that's what,
I'm sorry. We were all in the same way.
That's one of my questions
was how much did you improv?
And that wasn't clear.
It was good though.
It was.
So that's what I enjoyed about his dad
to beat his ass on the first day and all
that. And I would say, I would say hold
and they will stop right where they are.
Why does paypal and we would have to
freeze like that and he was like answering
or you have to set the cameras up,
but it,
it works well and it keeps, it keeps
the actors in the moment. Yeah.
And me being an actor, I want to be in
the moment. I want to, I didn't want,
I don't want to sit and do 5,000 takes
of something and I don't want to go and
get it in.
It can be two,
three created a models I'd
be on a Pallette is terrible.
You have created it.
Is
that it?
That is a bit of sweet of it.
After you do something like that and you
show up on set, yeah. You're like, right.
You know it's go. Yeah. Cause
we were sitting, we were doing
15 pages a day on the,
on the actual recording,
15 pages a day or you don't
understand what that means.
You have to understand what they shoot on
rate on a regular, a Hollywood picture.
They've shoot two pages that they
at the most, sometimes three.
If they get to three or four,
they think they're going really fast.
And we were at 1516 pages a day. So yeah.
Yeah. But that's how you normally work,
the efficiency of your production. Yeah.
It's kind of astounding. Couldn't do.
You could do a television series and a
day. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You can do a movie.
This one was done in
eight days. Yeah. Yeah.
We shoot the haves and have nots
in a day. And if, let me use wrong,
we shoot in a day, but, but a
lot of that is, it was about
a lot of that and we've
never done television.
That's how you get a job.
But you're on the,
you're on the biggest show on
television right now. Let's,
that's coming to an end at some point.
Just enjoy the ride. It's just
going to be around for a long time.
We'd know we shoot, we shoot him
date, what? But what happens in that,
cause I have a studio in Atlanta and part
of me building this studio was so that
I can do that. I can, I can go from
sing to sing set to set all on the base.
I don't have to travel across the city.
I don't have to go from stage to stage.
I built this world for me
to be able to do that. And,
and now it's become a world where other
films are coming to be filmed there.
Let's say a black panther
and universal shooting
condo forever
versus shooting their HBO know,
walking dead is shot.
There was a lot of things that are shot.
They're now so,
so it's a world that I created
that allows me to move that fast.
And I have a good team.
I bought a bunch of green folks that have
never done anything that wanted to be
in the business and taught them so well
that now they're breaking off and going
onto other films.
But,
but having all these young kids and a lot
of them people talking about inclusion
rider, I need a non inclusion
writer cause I got everything
body they already, that's
amazing. He actually goes to,
when he told me on Saturday,
he said I go to colleges and I hire these
kids that the industry is not going to
hire. That's why he's so blessed because
he just, he gave me my quote amount.
I don't know how many
people read my book but
they don't understand what quality is.
I never had a quote to be paid.
Like when I did all those movies,
y'all saw men up until I did the first
movie, I can do bad all by myself.
I was working with adequate,
which means they were paying
me chicken feed basically.
Where'd your quote this Sally,
you and moves used to but this has changed
but whatever your quote is this like
what did,
what did you,
what's the highest amount of money
you've ever gotten paid and whatever that
number is, that's what they based you
on. Well this is what we'll offer you.
And a lot of those
numbers were a lot lower.
So we set it then as at a higher
numbers higher than you ever had.
And even with this one I than
you've ever had. So it, it,
it changes the financial picture
for the actor and actresses. So,
and being able to do that
for her and a lot of others.
[inaudible]
no, no, no, no, no. He was
there. He was very generous with,
he's so cool. So cool. I just
want to hang out in his pocket.
Just go wherever he's going. Let
me go on now. And Larry Quick.
No real tall,
no real talky.
You were very generous and it's, uh, it's,
it's refreshing to be in
this crazy business and to
work with people who you're
not second guessing their,
their, you know, their,
their purpose and their reasons
for what they're doing. I was just,
just a good feeling to
be in that environment.
Yes.
I will always work with Mr. Tyler bear.
Well, it sounds like once you
go, Tyler, you'd never go back.
Well, what should they do? Really just,
Oh, so it was, it might have
just remained, just it just,
it goes when you win because
for me being a person that,
especially being a black
man in this business,
and this is not about racism at all,
this is just about race,
understanding that the value of
our own people and letting us know,
treating us all well, letting us
all, oh no, I mean if you walk,
if you came to the studio right now
and you walked through the campus,
cause it's a 330 acre campus and 12th
sound stages there and in the city of
Atlanta and you walk through the campus
and you see these kids in their faces
and,
and I,
I know every one of them meant to shake
their hands and the two to empower them,
make them feel,
I feel you,
you have to just drive through
the gates to really get it.
But that the energy and the
spirit of what is happening there,
I just wanted to, to permeate all over
the world. And I look at, you know,
for 10 years I was the only one out there.
The person of color doing,
making film and doing
television for a long time now.
And I took a lot of attacks because
people would come to my shows looking
forward themselves in my basket.
They're like, yeah, this shit ain't day.
Hey that ain't me.
They didn't represent black people.
That ain't so I took a lot of
hits for that. Right. But the,
but the issue with it is this,
the fighting the fights that I was having,
like paying people equally
and behind closed doors,
telling people that there are,
there are many of us who have
stories that need to be told.
So to sit here in this seat and see a
Esra on her show and to see empire and to
see Donald Glover on Atlanta to see
a Black Panther and Ryan Coogler,
I am celebrating man. I'm so happy that
this moment has arrived for so many,
but I caution but I caution them.
Yeah.
Cause I called a lot of people in
success. I said come, let's sit down.
Come to Atlanta, come, let's
sit down and let me talk to you.
Let me explain to you about ownership
because that is the way you really changed
things. We, this'll be a great
wave and then it'll go away.
Because if you look back at history,
we've seen this before, right?
This wave of this African American call,
everybody loves everybody
for seven years. Then it call the seven
years. That's what I'm is his birthday.
It's a cycle of seven years, seven
years, seven years. We get all my money.
I can't walk in and it's seven years on.
Yeah. And then, and then it goes away.
It's like I said,
but we hope that it's massive.
Does this owners,
this is what I'm trying to give everybody
that I meet with or talk to about
ownership, may owning all of my
copyrights. Me Owning all of my shows,
me owning every movie,
me owning everything has put me in a
position where where not only can I have a
studio where 9,000 people
that went through the gates
to come to work last year.
Wow.
But also to,
to have generational wealth for
my son and and his children.
And if they're, if they manage
it right after I'm dead and gone,
what that means is it's passed on to so
many people. So if you want real change,
real change comes with ownership.
As long as you're renting the house
and somebody else owns, owns it,
they have the power.
So that's what I'm trying to get a lot of,
a lot of us to come together
to understand and I'm, listen,
I'm an open door's open.
Come on
Laura. I want to own some stuff. When you
got all your own, that's fine. Don't yell.
Stop. I want to own my own
your stuff. You already own it.
You just said that I will come
some stuff together. Oh yeah.
That's not what I mean. Okay. You
know what I meant? Let's collaborate.
You can help me o Lord,
how much longer I got the VOP
you guys are at, you guys are pressed
for time. If you, if you're game,
we'd love to take a couple of questions
from the audience before we leave.
And while Googlers are lining up
either at that Mike or is that mine?
The hand.
I was like,
um,
I wanted to ask one last question.
Going back to the themes of the movie,
it seemed like you were,
you were,
you were not just writing a movie about
trust and betrayal and relationships,
but you were actually talking about and
poking at some big myths and stereotypes
about the strong black woman
or the angry black woman. Um,
could you talk a little bit about that?
Was that the,
was that the intent or was you just,
were you just like thrown in there though?
The
people, when people say things like, this
is always fascinates me, because when,
when I'm writing, I'm literally listening
to what the characters want to say. Hmm.
I'm not trying to make a statement.
I'm not trying to, to, to,
to make a point as much as it is,
let's, let's hear what she has to say.
And the more I wrote, the more
she showed up, the more she said.
What I realized this moment is about is
for all of those people who can't let go
for all of those people who can't forgive,
for all of those people who spend their
entire lives looking at what happened
with the one that got away rather than
going forward to see what else is out
there for them. Because what happens
a lot of times, especially with women,
is this is they,
after a bad divorce,
they feel like they have wasted the
best years of their life with someone.
And that promise was
supposed to be forever.
And the anger and the rage of that kid
can become bitterness and fester and
destroyed the person. So for
me, my hope and when people,
the takeaway is don't be her,
don't be harsh,
don't be her life goes on and whatever,
it didn't happen with you
and this person there,
there's somebody wonderful is you're
missing them because you are so stuck on
this and you've got all these people
passing you by. You can't even get to it.
And the happiest people I know are the
ones who came out of a divorce no matter
how ugly it was. And then ended up
finding the person of their dreams like,
oh my God, I'm so glad I went through
that because now I know how to treat you.
I know how to be there.
I knew and I know how to,
how this is how to make
this work. So yeah. Great.
First question. All right, thanks for
coming everybody. My question for you,
I think you hit on an interesting
subject in that the two sides of the
relationship is a common theme in your
movies. Kind of like the counseling.
Is that something that's really present
in your personal life or is there
another reason why you think
that's a common theme in your work?
You know what happened for me, I, I will.
I only wrote about experiences
that I knew or had some,
some something similar in my own life.
But what I found when I looked
back at some of the work now,
the ones that I can look at, cause I
can't look at all of them, a deal moves.
I said to going, I can't watch it.
But, but what I've found is when I'm,
when I'm writing about,
when I'm riding a black woman
and when I'm riding her struggle,
when I'm writing or paint or anyone for
that matter in any of the pain and what
she's going through,
I realized I was talking to my mother
because there's a little boy watching the
things that she went through.
I was hoping one day she would get it.
So if somebody sees something
that I've written and,
and it changes their life,
which has happened where people,
there have been women who have sent
me emails, they've been in terrible,
horrible relationships.
But after seeing, uh, uh,
I got this letter from a family that said,
you did attend and an hour and a half,
what we've been trying to do for 12 years,
my sister's leaving an
abusive relationship. So that
kind of, that's what, what,
what it's about for me.
So I realized early on that I was speaking
to her from the little boy that I was.
So I don't know who I was talking to
do for this one, but there we are.
Thank you.
Great. Hi. Thanks for coming. I saw
proud Mary by the way. I thought it was.
Yeah. So, um, you also, I saw also,
so one of your interviews where you were
talking about how they don't want to
bring black actors abroad and they
think, oh, you don't sell abroad. Um,
get with Tyler with you like your studio
and you're like basically owning the
whole vertical.
I think it's really powerful.
And including like what you
said about generational wealth.
I'm doing something
similar in real estate.
So I wanted to ask two questions.
One Tower,
do you see yourself expanding more into
the movie industry and like been doing
television, basically taking over some
more and to Rashia we're going to see you.
Um,
I'm pretty much in every area.
I am moving towards my own streaming
service though. I am moving towards. Yeah.
So that's what I, that's what
I'm working towards. But,
but when you talk about movies
not traveling internationally,
this is something that
we've been battling for many,
many years.
That's why the success of the success of
Black Panther spoke to so many levels.
Having international success because we
have been told for years that bed people
stories with people of color don't, don't
translate. They don't travel overseas.
And we've been trying to debunk that myth
for awhile because it's totally a myth.
I mean,
I was in China filming for
three months. China. Yeah.
And you know,
China is a very controlled,
a country is communist
still. Um, and you know,
you can't really watch movies there.
So they have these stores where you can
go get all of the DVDs from everything
and it's black market, you know, you
don't really go to jail for it. And Kevin,
unless they decide to stay. Yeah.
You don't get no money from it.
I saw every last one of my movies
there. Yeah. All of them I saw,
not easily broken there.
Right. Okay. That movie,
I don't even think did 700 theaters
here, but it was in China. Yeah.
So, you know, I don't understand
that. True. It's not true.
It's just that you have to spend
money to make money. You know, if you,
I have a personality,
I know I sell over there because empire
took me over there and I was in a room,
1500 standing room only.
They didn't call me cookie.
They call me Taraji Henson is,
was in Paris.
And I,
they didn't know I was in the audience
and lead Angela sitting on this on the
stage. And they, um, they
said they, they asked,
started asking a lot of cookie
question and he's, and he said, well,
why don't you ask her?
She's here.
When I stood up the entire room
stood up and started applauding.
I cry because I cry
because they lied to me.
I haven't been new China. Tell me,
these people just met me during empire.
So then we finish the Q and a.
I go outside,
they are coming up to me with every jacket
of all the movies that I had done it
right.
I was so in my feelings that entire trip,
that's our next battle.
That's our next time to prove that,
that we do so in international
markets that that is the
next battle. And, and, and,
and you know the thing about it,
of what you have to understand about this,
this is, I really do not
believe that this is the racism.
I really do not believe that. What
I believe is, as you just said,
you spend money to make money and,
and somebody has to make the initial
investment in going over there.
Will Smith was brilliant when he took me
over a, he was doing seven pounds. He,
I was like, I want to break it and
break in over there. Said, come, come,
let me explain something to you.
So we went to [inaudible],
I went to seven territories with him
and watched how he worked at and he had,
but he had a a way in from, from, uh,
wrap and fresh prince so long
before. So, so it's, it's,
it's just we're getting there. It's a slow
thing. It's a fight. But we've got to,
we've got to convince more
people to spend the money. Yeah.
Just what if it fails,
I'll lose my job.
But somebody has to have the balls to
take a chance to take a leap of faith
because it's going to blow. Like it'll
happen if you just take a chance. Right.
If somebody just takes a chance on me
next week,
Rajiv, thank you so much for
coming. And um, your role in empire.
Like I mean I've started watching the
beginning of me of my husband love,
we have to be a part of this week.
This is just so powerful to see just all
these different emotions in this depth,
in this character that,
you know,
growing up like there was a few
examples but now it's just overwhelming.
It's so amazing. What the choice. Um,
but you guys mentioned something like
this lie of like not being able to sell.
And I think back to the point
you made about payment, right?
Like how you know the statistics black
women and like it next women are making
so much less. And what are your thoughts
on the transparency around that?
Cause you just mentioned that you
got a quote in the beginning and the
transparency on being able to say there
are people who are willing to pay me for
what I'm worth, so I don't need
to accept that from someone else.
How do we change that?
Like with more transparency around
people who are doing it. Right. Okay.
Well I tell you what's changing in
the industry right now. You can't big,
they don't go off quotes anymore, which
is great. So at whatever, whatever,
whatever, a movie or are you off like
before you can call it a page and a goal.
Okay. What's a quote? Oh she
made this amount of money
on the last movie, So, okay,
so, so you, I'm going
to offer that now with,
with everything that's happening with
equality and inclusion and diversity,
the, the industry standard is you
cannot ask what someone's quote is,
which is,
which is a good thing.
And a lot of ways it's slowing down a
lot of the negotiations because people
don't know what to ask. So what did what
to offer. So they're starting really,
really low now. But, but it also sets,
it erases that moment of I'm going to
pay you based on what your lasting was as
opposed to I'm going to pay
you off on where you are now.
What's your worth is
and what you're doing.
Okay. So the here's where all my
hard work for 20 years come in.
We got,
cause I know one thing I can do,
I can open the film, I can get you
what you paid on your film back.
I know that much now with the help of
the studio, I can get you even more.
So you gotta pay me now.
That's right. Thank you.
Cause I'm a Black Cup.
Hey, we thought that you guys
are here. Thank you so much.
Um, so my question is about your past
history together, working on other films.
Um, so which one was your
favorite that you guys did?
My favorite is the family that prays.
So I just wanted to know what your
favorite is and then also what is the
difference or your preference between
working together as actors and just acting
versus directing. Cause I know you do
both Tyler. So what's your preference?
What are the differences?
My favorite is this one.
We've done it here and once you see it,
I think you know why?
It's just the level of growth from,
from a family that prays to this.
I'm proud of the level of growth
that I've experienced, but also just,
I love being an eye.
I love acting with her,
but I much rather director because I'm,
I'm,
I want to be behind the camera and I'm
leaning toward more and more that way.
Oh, I as time goes on, but,
but working with her on this
with was just, yeah. Yeah.
It's actors enjoy working with them.
It doesn't matter.
Cause if he's been in front of the camera,
not that I'm saying,
he's also directing himself too.
So,
and I, and I can't, when
I'm directing myself,
I can't have as much fun as if
I'm just directing the film. So
yeah. Thank you so much. Yeah. Yeah.
I do enjoy you better when
you're just directing.
Oh, they just so much for
coming in. This is so fun.
So you're talking about I'm all your long
days on set and being really efficient
in that time.
So it was just kind of curious like what
are your non negotiables when you first
show up on set first day,
like what do you need there and what kind
of do to rejuvenate yourself and like
reenergize
you want me to go get you a ride
or do you want no kidding. She had,
she had a requirement of crab legs.
No, talking down to you, don't you?
I don't require much.
I don't,
I don't mean just crab legs and one
eye rolls or Matt check and see rose.
All your techs, they're all
day long as you get that right.
I don't care what's in the trail, I get
it myself. I know. Right, right. I don't,
I don't have any crazy requirements.
What I asked
just cause, cause I just, I just did
a film recently where, where, um,
I ended up paying for a lot of
stuff myself because, because
they didn't want to basically, so, so
eh. And I'm okay with that because I'm,
I'm okay to go and improve myself and
show you what I can bring to the table.
So I don't have all the, I cut a bunch of
crazy requirements. I don't need a lot.
Just I have a bag with my own
stuff in and then we go from there.
And then what do you kind of do at the
end of the day to like rejuvenate and
like get ready for the next day?
The smoke weed.
Oh No, no, no, no. Really, no,
no, no. I thought it was a shock for me.
For me. I know you don't want
those elite shot, is that
right? No, no, no. I've never,
I've never done, I've never done
drugs, but I do have trouble.
I do have trouble sleeping.
So, um, so what I, what I,
what I started doing was
having some buckets and then
I realized this could be a
problem if you keep doing this. So right
now what I'm trying to train myself,
he has to let them calm my mind
down enough to go to sleep without,
without anything. But I did try. We drink
once this a friend of mine, she said,
you've got to take, try this to help
you sleep. Because she had stayed.
She had tried ambien and that she would,
and this was working, this was perfect.
This will help you sleep. So I'm like,
okay. I tried it, took a shot of it,
didn't nothing happened.
Next night. She said,
well take two and nothing happened next.
I just didn't take three
because you're a big guy.
Maybe say start took three shots at
that. We'd drink. It was a pink lemonade.
Do my legs,
my leg started growing. I
couldn't open. I couldn't,
I was trying to pull my mouth open.
It wouldn't open.
Then she facetimed me and I was
hiding behind the camera for that.
God,
if you get me out of this,
I will never
ever touch this weed stuff again
in my life. So what owl? I relaxed.
I just lay there until I fall asleep.
Let last question.
We've got to go. Sorry. Nope, we're, we've
talked to about it was the last question.
Sorry. We have, we can't, we
can't let it go real quick.
Okay.
Questioning Kinda changed,
right?
You have, what can I can, I can, okay.
All right. So first off, thank you all
for coming. Uh, that ain't no question.
No, I am really quick. I
just want you to be thankful,
be thankful. So a two part
question, really fast one. Uh,
like although I know I look like Ryan
Coogler I am not as talented as he.
So are you going to have any or do you
plan to open up and actually start having
some screenwriting classes or things of
that nature that we can maybe attend if
we want to start getting
into your industry.
And then the second thing is I do you
have any plans to come to Broadway so that
we can increase the amount of black
faces that we see there as well?
I think,
yeah,
I'm definitely going to a
startup incubators where we
have system where we have
talent once the studio is completely
finished being built where we bring talent
in from all over the places,
writers, directors, producers.
Cause cause you know,
I'm 48 and, and I'm going to start slowing
down. So I'm looking for the next wave.
So definitely, definitely going to
do that. And as far as Broadway goes,
I'm thinking about working on
a one man show and finally,
finally taken on Broadway. So I'm,
I'm, I'm thinking about doing that.
Why would first, so come see my
one woman show first and then,
okay, great. Great. All right, cut.
Um,
well my question originally changed
cause you went to your extracurricular
activities. No, I'm just
putting it, what's it called?
I was going to say like, do you,
what's your favorite, but anyways,
oh that's a good question.
Is for lyric, right?
I kind of wanted it to bring the attention
onto you, so I liked what you did,
what she's got to have it. I was hoping
that a little Nola was going to pick you,
but uh, it happens. How do you,
how do you like playing
the love triangle role?
Like I feel like you're always
involved with like multiple people.
Let me ask you,
what's your personal life
and your
answer?
That's it.
I did not mean to put you on blast.
I don't mind playing those characters
because they're real characters, right?
People could relate to them. Um, I
like, I like real, I like raw, like,
you know,
moments where is it?
It takes over and it's not you
being cerebral about it. So, uh,
like to you said earlier, if I'm not,
if I'm not scared or nervous about,
then something's wrong.
So I like when I'm nervous and scared and,
and I'm entering a new
territory I know nothing about,
which is why I had a lot of fun
working in this environment. Um,
cause it was really scary. And um, it
is because as an actor you want to,
you want it, you want to be
professionally. You want to
know that your abilities,
Eh, you know, you, you have the ability to
get the job done. And when you're there,
each night you talk about winding down. I
couldn't because I'm thinking, God, what,
what, what happened today?
You know, there's a lot of
this movie, I don't remember.
No, no, no, no, that's
real. Because like he said,
we were filming 15 pages a day
and I've not done that before.
I've not done that before. So a,
you know, a lot of these interviews,
it's not because I'm super quiet,
it's, I just don't remember stuff. So,
um, so when I hear them talk, I then I
wrote, I'm like, Oh yeah, I remember that.
It's like, it's jogging my memory
and I it, but it felt right.
It felt right and there was never a time
when I was really questioning, you know,
if we're getting it because the child
was saying, you know, Todd was saying,
we got it. We got it. And, um,
they're saying that I'm not answering.
No,
but
he's happily, happily married. We got to
wrap up. Yeah, exactly. The last question.
He's happily married. He's
happily married UCI, he ran off.
Thanks so much for coming. Um, Tyler,
love you forever. So many great movies.
Teraji 11th grade. I love
you Jody. That was, it.
Took me home love lyric in
Jamaica, Kingston. Born and bred.
Respect. Um, really quick question.
I just wanted to know what were you
guys next big project that you'd like to
work on?
Are you already working on now?
Well, I'm working on, um,
uh, uh, what men want.
What does a remake of what women want
that Mel Gibson did with Helen Hunt?
Yeah.
Good ladies we get to hit with mainly.
Okay.
But that's coming out after mine comes
out in November. It's called the,
it's called the list with Tiffany Haddish,
Omari Hardwick.
And because you were promoted
and won't be Goldberg is doing the castle.
Oh, she might be joining my movie too.
Okay.
And layer it up.
I'll be, um, I got, uh, I got a film
coming out called Natalie ever after.
Oh.
Uh, again, um, you know, it's full
of women. I like when women. Okay.
Yes. Represent, represent females. What
are you doing? He didn't say courts.
I was going to say, it says, it
says wrap it up him around. Okay.